في يوم آخر ، هناك عنوان
آخر لن يفوز بقطر أي مشجع جديد
تشك فيه في أجزاء معينة من العالم ، وهو
مكالمة ضخمة قبل 48 ساعة فقط
من انطلاق كأس العالم ، وهو أمر
محرج حقيقي للهيئة الحاكمة لكرة القدم العالمية
FIFA وواحد.  من
أكبر رعاتهم ،
لن يتم بيع كحول بدويايزر للجماهير في الملاعب ،
سيتم تقديمه في مناطق الضيافة وما زال
في مهرجان فان ، ولكن داخل
الملاعب سيكون برعم صفر ، هذه بطولة
تتحدى
القواعد والأعراف منذ البداية.  منحت كأس العالم
وسط فضيحة فساد أول
بطولة كأس عالم شتوية على الإطلاق تقام في
الشرق الأوسط في بلد مسلم ، إنها
قصة مختلفة تمامًا عن
الجدل والمخاوف التي
تحدثنا عنها في مجال الإنسان
حقوق معاملة العمال
المهاجرين وأعضاء مجتمع LGBTQ plus
ولكن ما تفعله يلقي بظلال من الشك
على ما يجب أن يتوقعه الناس خلال
الأسابيع الخمسة المقبلة من الضمانات التي
تم تقديمها على مدار الـ c  هذه
البطولة وما بعدها أماندا ديفيس الدوحة
قطر